ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show we are here again uh Britney
Spears um has got to go back in uh I've
been watching Britney Spears videos for
the last couple of days I've had off and
I've been on the beach and I've been
looking at uh Britney Spears and I've
been deciding that parents know their
children
and any parent that locks their child up
is not doing it by accident any parent
that tells the world my child cannot be
with you is not doing it I think uh out
of uh any type of a situation where
there's a choice I truly believe that
we've now seen the benefits of a
conservatorship we should now be trying
to we should put more people in
conservatorships I don't think this this
is a win for the conservatorship model
of life where your rights are stripped
from you and you are kept in your
domicile not abused not hurt but kept in
your domicile by someone who knows
better her father clearly knew better oh
you think I'm wrong take a look take a
look at the clip
take a look at our evidence
put her in
[Music]
put her back
all you should hear is the clink of a
cell closing
yeah I mean this she looks like a a a a
drunk girl
like from Long Island
who's like out on Tuesday night instead
of watching her kids
throw her in a closet for 20 years which
is what needs to happen someone needs to
grab her you know the dog catches from
lady in the [__]
said there needs to be a truck to throw
her in and then take her somewhere that
she cannot leave
this is not a purse and there's a new
Britney Spears documentary coming out
that all the celebrities are worried
about there's articles about that saying
that all of these celebrities are
worried that Britney Spears is going to
Dime on them that she's gonna say
something like the so-and-so touched me
or raped me or I was 15 and that one
grabbed me because supposedly it is a
very graphic
um documentary or to an autobiography
that they're adapting into a documentary
I think it's a documentary I don't think
she's writing well she wouldn't be
writing but I think what it is is kind
of like a tell-all and she's going to
you know she came up in Hollywood she
was in The Mickey Mouse Club I mean the
things that she could say probably about
certain people would be very damaging
there's probably people now going we
cannot have that documentary come out
about uh Brittany because uh she's going
to talk about the time I did something I
should not have done uh you know
backstage at The Mickey Mouse Club I was
not always there's people sitting there
going oh they're drinking scotch in
their backyard they're going you know
what I was not always well behaved when
I was backstage at The Mickey Mouse Club
I was a little bit you know those were
the old days you know you could just
have fun who knew what age these people
were so she's gonna come out in probably
you know a few people's days are going
to be dampened by uh these Revelations
that she was brought I mean this is
probably the result and I don't know
this I'm not I'm speaking out of turn as
I often do but this is probably the
result of abuse at some point in her
life at the hands of one or many people
my guess my non-medical guess this is my
non-medical guess that at some point in
her life uh when she started out as what
a Mouseketeer wasn't she a Mouseketeer
right so between
Mouseketeer and now I believe at some
point not MediCal gas there was massive
abuse at some point sexual physical
verbal at some point between Mouseketeer
and
there was a real problem and if she
talks about it it's going to make a lot
of people uncomfortable
this is to take not all child actors are
going to end up like me you know what I
mean like not all child actors are going
to end up uh very well adjusted
homosexual ex-cocaine addict
multi-millionaires uh who are very
successful in their chosen field that's
not going to happen to everybody I've
had a few bumps along the way I'm not a
perfect child I'm sure if you know you
were my parents I mean or or anyone's
parents you'd want a quiet uh you know
lacrosse playing Finance guy that has a
litter of children and a big house in
Westchester County New York and you know
has a wife that loves throwing parties
but you don't have that you have a x gay
cocaine attitude things Trump makes a
few good points and that's not anyone's
idea of perfection when you have a child
that's not something that you would go
for necessarily because you would think
of XK cocaine addict when at the very
least not say something about
immigration that would make a dinner
party go called
it's about into next gay cocaine addict
because I knew a lot there was a guy who
used to sell me cocaine named Albert and
he was not from America
and
but what was good about him and shout
out to him if he watches some of them do
and I don't mean undocumented people
although you're welcome to I mean people
I used to know in my past
Albert had yellow Coke which was good
you know Coke should be a little pink or
a little yellow like it should have a
little it should be a little off color
when you get cooked it's too white it's
been stepped on which means it's been
cut up a lot with things like out of
stall the 100 cut maybe they're on other
things now I don't know speed whatever I
loved Coke you're loved loved with an ed
yes I don't do it I have natural energy
I don't care what you say like Marianne
Williamson I you cannot touch me I have
a chakra that protects me but the
cocaine that I got from Albert was
really really amazing it was uh
off-white lovely color and he barely
spoke English and and sometimes we'd go
meet his cousin in the Bronx
and I don't know if they were documented
or not and it doesn't matter and I'm not
saying that all undocumented people with
drug dealers I don't even know how I got
here I was talking about Britney Spears
being abused at the mouse camp but but
my point is that
if you are undocumented and you are
selling drugs they should at least be
good drugs right because we're expecting
it to be a higher quality a better class
but the border is becoming a problem the
border is the border the Border because
show these videos there are people just
running around down there it's like
spring break except no one's having fun
it's the Texas border and everybody's
running around and everybody's waiting
on a line but no one's going to Splash
Mountain it's a horrible thing all of
these uh migrants and that's what you
call them
I said that the other day and they're
like I don't think that's the term
someone literally said I don't think
that's the term I'm like migrant is
absolutely the term look at all these
people okay
this is uh this is very sad all of these
people have come to America because
they're worried about Britney Spears and
they are no they're here for a better
life uh they're here for uh jobs some of
them are probably here to do bad things
but we don't know who's who and what's
what and it's a flood of people into the
country and we don't know where to put
them and now they're shipping them
around like a political football like
they sent 30 of them outside Kamala
Harris's house and then they ship them
to New York and then Eric Adams probably
our mayor asked them for blow and then
uh if they couldn't provide that he
shipped them out you remember a while
ago Governor DeSantis of Florida shipped
them to Martha's Vineyard
um it's like hot potato with these
people's lives which is very sad because
they are human beings but also they are
seeing a lot of the country you know
that is something no to be honest I mean
they're seeing more of the country the
people that have lived here a long time
like the idea that these governors keep
sending them different places to piss
off other Governors you're seeing
Martha's Vineyard you're seeing DC
you're seeing New York these are the
prime spots
um and and I just you know it is sad
because these are human being and I
often think what if I was a migrant
I think about this sometimes I do
I you know and a lot of people say no
you don't but I do and it would be so
different to be a migrant
uh then I you know because you it's
you're coming from a place of total
desperation because you are clinging to
anything right
and you're in America and you're just
kind of you don't know what's going to
happen now a lot of these obviously a
lot of these migrants are hard workers
they're willing to work they will work
um they're not bad people they're not
here to cause harm some of them are
those are probably outliers a small
group of them that are bad and and not
good and not you know but what is the
economic cost of absorbing the amount of
immigrants that we've absorbed it's a
lot right it's truly a lot it's not it's
not easy for any country to take in
everybody you know and you get
everybody's got to have a place to go
and I feel like these people right now
don't have a place to go so there were
30 of them were sent to kamala's house
and what has come of that I don't know
what is she
well usually what happens is they put
them back on a bus and then they take
them to like like another ice detention
center right but like this I think this
looks like either DC or imagine them
listening to Kamala Harris talk and then
they decide they want to go back to
their country they go she's the vice
president
she's like folks I'll tell you this
freedom is freeing for you for all
and thus in the way that I believe today
we can make a better Union strong and
that she walks back in what's she saying
here is she this was a word salad the
other day no I don't believe it
I'm barely working
what's she saying over here
that's correct
my mother used to she would give us she
didn't have a mother she would say
what's wrong with you young
[Laughter]
context
yeah she's great I love I am I'm telling
you right now I can't explain to people
how big of a fan I've become of her as
of late
um I I I cannot explain this new
Alzheimer's
ant thing she's got like early stage
dementia and things she's got going on
where she's like you young people think
you fell out of a coconut tree but what
you actually are
is you're here and it's like the
craziest thing like I think at this
point that's what I would do because all
of these problems really are so
unsolvable I think maybe that's what I
would do if people are like what are we
gonna do about the Border I'm like my
mother used to say to me you think you
backed up into a cactus but that's your
ass talking you know people like what
are you what are these colloquialisms
these strange sayings
she's become [__] the guy from House
of Cards Uh Kevin Spacey who used to do
all those things my father used to say
back in Gaffney my father had a saying
back in Gaffney that's that's literally
what she's become so many times I'm
trying to buy tickets I'm really
stressed out I'm trying to find them
last minute hunting down the best price
competing with other buyers for a
popular event buying tickets your
favorite event shouldn't be stressful
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer deals
on last minute tickets and the best
prices guaranteed you can stop stressing
over the tickets and start getting hyped
for all the fun you're gonna have so
many of my friends are using the game
time app right now to get Taylor Swift
tickets okay Flash Deals last minute
tickets easy to find and buy tickets for
every concert in your area images of
seat views knowing exactly where you're
gonna sit lowest price is guaranteed
event cancellation protection job loss
protection amazing game time is a place
for last minute ticket deals you
shouldn't be using anything else okay
snag the tickets without the stress
download the game time at create an
account and use code Tim for twenty
dollars off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code Tim for twenty percent off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed everyone wants
to learn a foreign language if you're
taking an upcoming summer trip abroad my
go to travel hack is Babel whether
you're a seasoned traveler or embarking
on your first Adventure communication is
key to fully experiencing a new culture
you go to Italy people are going to
think you're a fat uncultured slob how
about learning some Italian okay Babble
is the language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to Babel's addictively fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination with
Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having a real live conversation in as
little as three weeks Apple's actually
crafted lessons are built around real
life you can learn how to have practical
conversations about travel relationships
business and more other language
learning apps use AI for their lesson
plans but Babble lessons were created by
over 150 language experts and voiced by
real native speakers not computers their
teaching method can be scientifically
proven to be effective
with Babel it's easy you can choose 14
different languages Babble speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent there are
so many ways to learn with Babel in
additional lessons you can access
podcast Games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning Journey today with
Babel right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to
babble.comtim that's battle.com
50 off 55 off your subscription when you
go to babel.com
t-i-m we cannot solve this border now
what are where are the migrants coming
from because they're coming from Mexico
and they're coming
uh over the board because these border
states like Texas are really doing with
it can we bring them in Austin bring
them to Austin
now what is the priest saying oh yeah I
want to hear this priest because what's
he saying
is is he making a statement that Jesus
would would want this to happen because
that's what these priests always do they
go if Jesus were alive he'd be helping
these migrants I don't know about that
there's a lot of [__] that Jesus might
be into now like Bitcoin
like would Jesus be a total loser it's a
good question if Jesus were around today
maybe maybe he would be a total loser
but maybe he wouldn't like if Jesus were
alive today he would literally be the
worst person on Twitter he'd be like a
cab
and you'd be like shut up Jesus you
don't even live in a bad area you've
never even dealt with crime shut up a
cab shut up everything's white supremacy
you'd be like oh my God it's so annoying
everyone that purports to love Jesus
that would hate him Jesus would be on
Twitter all day he'd be leading marches
he'd be doing crazy [__] he'd be like
outside Mar-A-Lago with a sign I mean he
would be the worst unless he changed
some of his views what does this priest
have to say about the migrants
hello I'm Bishop Mark get out wouldn't
that be great imagine some long-lost
family members show up at your door
I would throw them out we are all part
of the nope family and that is not stop
him now Mark Mark
knew
because here's the deal I'm allowed to
refuse to migrants if I could refuse my
own family
done and done
Mark is that the value proposition you
want to set up because done and done
he's like if long lost members of Europe
can you imagine by the way imagine that
just
hello hey what's up hey man
um if you're Dylan right yeah and uh
you're related to like uh you know uh uh
your grandfather and your grandmother
you know your grandfather's brother
yeah well I
was a crazy story but he actually had
another family he he cheated on his wife
and he and Hey Hey where's this going
man we're just going I never even met
that guy well anyway I'm like I guess
you're long-lost cousin I guess I'd be
like a second cousin once removed
uh yeah uh maybe I don't I'm bad with
that I don't I don't I don't really know
that lineage stuff at all well anyway I
need somewhere to say yeah dude I really
don't know what this has to do with me
um uh sorry uh also in addition to me
there's 30 migrants from Central America
absolutely not to both of you get the
[__] out
ow
I had friends stay at my house I
immediately regretted it immediately I
was out of town immediately they left a
thing of pasta in the refrigerator not
even like nice
they just made pasta and left it in the
refrigerator like without a sauce or it
wasn't even a dish was just like oh I
had excess pasta I had extra
carbohydrates and I'm gonna leave it in
your refrigerator it was just not nice
let's see if he comes around I don't I
don't like this Human family stuff
now our our lost brothers and sisters
this is the time El Paso for us to live
up to us as dirtbags
what is El Paso's reputation by the way
what is El Paso's reputation
what does ELP like live up to the
reputation of el Pasa it's known for
salsa
Old El Paso is known for making salsa
that they're not known for taking people
in they're not known for being
christ-like they're known for making
jars of pretty decent salsa
so when he goes we have to live up to
our reputation I'm a little confused as
to what he means we need to live up to
our reputation of making a salsa and we
need to bring those people if he said
that see that's the argument they need
to make it's like an economic argument
he's like we need to bring these people
in and have to make our salsa our Old El
Paso salsa that's what we do that's what
we are and it'll seem more authentic if
it's made by people that aren't white
and you go that's interesting and then
he goes then there's more money for all
of us because he goes even though I'm a
priest we need money I like things I
like watches he goes I fly private he
goes actually I'm the chief Faith
officer of the church that I live in uh
I I'm barely a priest I do more of the
business stuff and I'm telling you right
now that bringing these migrants in is
going to free you up to do things you've
always wanted to do you don't want to
cut your grass or do your wife's Nails
migrants can help they come over and do
the jobs you don't want to do and I've
been working with the Chamber of
Commerce hammering out some numbers and
what we've realized is that in El Paso
by replacing all of the jobs that we're
playing Americans with with migrants we
can let the rich people have a lot more
money to donate to the church and put
into our sexual abuse fund
um let's see the rest of this I'm
unimpressed and unswayed by this man
welcoming right now our Diocesan family
is opening four parish-based shelters
and with your help we are about to open
only for the kids though all of our
parishes and Priests are working to
support the effort by preparing food by
volunteering at one of our shelters and
by praying for them by the way by the
way could they have done some of this
for Americans that have broken in El
Paso and I'm not saying they're not but
you know what I mean like having
Americans been broken El Paso for a
while
is it right some of them are probably
undocumented too like having people that
have been here for a while couldn't they
use a couple of shelters and folks see
this is the problem everybody says oh
you're heartless in your heart I'm not
heartless I'm just saying that
there doesn't there's no get up and go
when it comes to like Americans
of any color by the way there's no get
up and go where's his like let's help a
disadvantage disenfranchise black
Americans with shelters where's that
how about that where's that Father Mark
there's none of that he's like now is
our time when we're on the news
now is our time when we're on the news
here's what I mean by that this is the
time when there's cameras pointed in
every direction
this is our time not when before when it
was just poor people and we said that's
fine
but now when cameras are being pointed
at us we we realize it's time to
shift The Narrative from we're a clan of
child abusers to look here's a shelter
and we've made mashed potatoes for these
people
[Laughter]
time to switch our narrative just a
little bit here in the Old El Paso
Ministry of rape
let's finish it
the next several weeks could be
challenging could be but we are not
alone in this the Lord is at our side
hey man I hope it works out I don't you
know obviously it's a comedy show but I
don't want anyone to die
I don't want any of these people to be
mistreated I just think we cannot
continually have this system that we
have where the country is flooded with
people
um and there's nowhere to put them we
are using them as a political football
um it does not seem Humane to do this
country has absorbed a lot of immigrants
we will absorb more I'm not somebody who
believes in no immigrants what I'm
saying is like this is a massive failure
of our current government and anyone
looking at this has to say that any
fair-minded honest human being has to
really go you know this is not the good
system there needs to be a system and
frankly you know I think right now
America needs uh to just you know it's
kind of like
when the parties fall a little bit it's
like let's just rock out with who we
have right now let's not have kids from
another 10 schools come in we were
rocking out right now with who we have
we got a lot of people people are
already throwing up there was two fights
uh the cops were called once they were
kind of cool about it but they left but
if we keep bringing in people there's
gonna be more fights people are going to
get sicker someone's gonna break [__]
Dennis's mom's [__] lamp that she
[__] loves more than her family and
then everybody's gonna start screaming
and yelling and then eventually what
will happen to this party is like
there's going to be a group of Nazis in
the party Who start going to the rest of
the party being like there's so many
[__] people coming in we can't have
any fun anymore and in order and then a
lot of people at the party gonna go yeah
I know it's kind of a problem but you're
seemingly really crazy like you want me
to embrace all these ideas like yeah the
only way to safeguard this party forever
is to come over to our side where it's
only white people in the party and you
go wait a minute that doesn't really
make any sense that doesn't make any
sense we like uh Hispanic people and
black people they make the party funner
and they go yeah but there's so many of
them and then you're like this doesn't
make any sense but then all of a sudden
there's like crashing and screaming and
then you can't really see what's
happening in the party because a smoke
machine someone hired is malfunctioning
and you start going well I know this
white guy maybe this white guy he can
help me to another room and then he just
leads you and then you get in the room
and then there's pictures of Hitler my
point is that's not exactly what I'm
trying to say but it is it is right now
we're our country where there's the
party is at Max Capacity by adding more
people people are just gonna get
disoriented and disoriented people make
bad decisions they do and they just
start going like you know hey uh let's
like all racially identify let's
identify
by races which is not true it should
identify by classes who has more than
others
that's the way it's always been and
that's kind of fair
it's a republican show we had a
communist show two shows ago
but
we should we certainly shouldn't
identify by classes or races we should
identify by regions right maybe no I
don't know maybe we should identify by
individual Merit and behavior that's
interesting probably not but I'm just
saying no matter what happens you don't
want immigration would be an issue that
these people keep demagoguing all the
time the people in the right wing
demagogue it so they don't have to
explain why vast chasms of wealth
inequality continue to persist persist
in this developed Nation the Democrats
demagogue this issue because so they
don't have to explain ultimately the
same thing why people don't have health
care you know why uh you know kids are
going to bed hungry uh why people have
you know less uh of a chance at retiring
at a a decent age or sending their kids
to college all these things that should
matter to regular Americans this issue
kind of drowns out every other issue so
that's why it's best to solve it and
that's almost why it seems like nobody
wants it solved but it is difficult to
solve because at the end of the day
people in America are you know we don't
want I don't want anybody to feel like
they can't
go to an airport Kentucky Fried Chicken
which to me is what's left of this
country
what's left of this country if you were
not insanely wealthy
is in the Miami Airport there's a
Kentucky Fried Chicken and there's a
Pizza Hut right next to it and the Pizza
Hut the pizzas have been left under the
warmer for so long that the cheese is
all browned and it's like a scab it's
like skin when the woman cuts it she's
cutting through the skin of a once great
Empire and next to it there are people
that are eating chicken sandwiches
before they get on a flight before it's
the last thing they remember of America
before they go back to Santo Domingo or
wherever they're going they take they
get chick frat greasy fried chicken and
eat it with mashed potatoes and macaroni
and cheese before they get on a plane
and then they touch the plain seeds with
their greasy fingers but I want everyone
to have that experience I don't want
anyone to not have that experience I
want you to be able to take your kids to
laser tag I want your kids to be able to
get addicted to drugs I want you to be
able to put them in a program I want you
to be able to become friends with a
woman who runs that program who's named
Jennifer who's a little fat who's an
ex-alcoholic but owns a bar and you go
that doesn't really make sense but
whatever you know the kids really like
her and I want uh you to drop your kids
off at that program every Wednesday and
then I want your son to tell you that
he's really excited because he has a
month sober and you're really proud of
him and you go out to a dinner and
everybody's still very anxious because
it's only a month sober but it's still
really cool that he did it you know and
then fat Jennifer the [__] weird
ex-alkie but still owns a bar that runs
the program is at the dinner too and
your son's 16 and she's 28 and then
eventually you know you find out that
Jennifer is pregnant with your son's
child okay and she's gonna have his baby
and instead of putting her in jail
you've researched the consent laws and
you decide to just let it go you decide
to actually let it go you decide to let
it go because you think a baby actually
might be a good thing and it might keep
your son on the right track you decide
to let it go you decide to let the
molestation of your son at the hands of
his drug counselor go
and you have that baby and that baby is
very cute and it's very fat and it's
chubby and it doesn't know where it is
and you realize when you see that baby
that this is the promise of new life
this is the promise of America and this
is the greatness your 16 year old son
was molested by his drug counselor
Jennifer but he is sober now and he's
working construction but Rhonda Santos
is now instituted the e-verify in
Florida which means your son can no
longer work at the construction job he
comes home and he's upset you can smell
the beer on his breath the cerveza and
he's angry and you say son why and why
aren't you at work you have a baby and
your son goes because Ron DeSantis
um is enforcing e-verify which means I
need a social security number in order
to work and you're like [__] this is
[__] up [__] my undocumented son who's
molested by his drug counselor who had
this very cute little baby is working
every day at a construction site which
has now been shut down because Ron
DeSantis is instituted e-verify meaning
that my son cannot go to his
construction job for to pay for the baby
he had with his [__] drug counselor
who molested him
what are uniquely American situation
and then you start going well what can
my son do
what can your son do it's so hard right
he can't do anything official so listen
he starts moving a little bit of weight
he starts selling drugs and in the
beginning you judge him for it you judge
him for it because at the end of the day
you say [__] you know isn't there
anything else he can do but then he
starts bringing home some money then he
starts bringing home some money and then
there's a new crib and then he was able
to actually pay for a new bathroom for
you in your little house
and you're like wow this is kind of
amazing and you know at the end of the
day we have so much money now even if he
gets caught and locked up which God
forbid ideas meow you would never want
to happen even if he gets locked up you
still have enough money to care for that
little chubby baby that he got and his
wife comes around every now and then to
see the kid they're no longer together
which makes sense I mean these teacher
student things don't last but she comes
around and you've smacked her up a few
times she's a drunk and she comes there
all sloppy and drunk with her tits out
and you go listen you're lucky you're
not in jail you [__] rapist be the
fan and you say you go bid the fair in
that like Venezuelan accent
and she comes around to see the baby but
you let her see her baby and your son's
finally making good money selling drugs
because Ron DeSantis made him not a
construction worker and your son
actually says to you sometimes like yeah
you still [__] make the construction
now I'm the king and he go actually to
be honest with you he's doing very well
and your son sells all of this cocaine
and he starts actually
you know just he's got this street team
of kids doing it for him and he's very
smart and he has this system where as
soon as anyone gets caught he kills them
so they don't rat on him he actually
kills him they're 13 they're 14. he
kills them all so they can't rat on him
and it's very heartless but people are
willing to take the chance because he's
paying them so much money he's paying
them an inordinate amount of money to do
this they get much higher percentages
than any Street Runner kids do but they
know they have the chance if they get
caught they get rocked and he uses
younger and younger children because
they evade the police so he's using 12
year olds and 13 year olds to sell Coke
and every now and then he has to kill
one of them and you kind of know this
because you've heard it from people but
you refuse to really look at the ins and
outs of his business because it doesn't
really matter you know and you remember
Coming to America and you remember you
know how hard it was and you're still
undocumented and you you'd be cleaning
toilets and [__] folding laundry and
you know how tough it is and all you
want is to have that American dream and
your son is ironically having that dream
by building a cocaine Empire okay and
he's working with white people now and
business owners he's laundering money
because they get involved too and you
know he's hanging out with political
people and then eventually he gets you
all citizenship your son gets you all
citizenship by being a cocaine dealer
and servicing very well because your son
also and I hate to say this I don't want
to say this the children that are
selling cocaine he's also pimping out to
high-end business uh people and
political leaders so your son is a human
trafficker as well now he's a human
trafficker and you hate the idea of that
but he's doing so well he's doing so
well he's a human trafficker and a Norco
trafficker and he's doing well though
and he's getting respect right and then
he decides to run for Congress
your son decides to run for Congress and
you're so proud of him and you're crying
when you're and he gets elected of
course why not he's he's an undocumented
guy
who became documented who went through
the process who fought his way up and
you know we people don't really know
exactly how he made his money but it's
just construction or real estate and
at the end of the day when you're
standing there when he first becomes a
congressman and he's done it on the
bodies of children on the bodies of
women on the bodies of the poor on the
bodies of families he's done it with
drugs he's done it with human
trafficking I want you to see when he
takes that photo and that that still
moment in time where he becomes a
congressman he's done it just like
everyone else has he's an American now
and so are you and I want you to have
that experience I do I want you to have
that experience
as someone who comes to our country I
want your son to have that chance
I you know what I don't know if it's
going to work out like that but I want
your kid to have that chance of becoming
a drug dealer a human trafficker and
then a congressman
that's what I want because that is the
American [__] dream okay raycon is my
favorite earbuds ever okay their premium
audio the perfect price points you can
listen to what you want when you want
without breaking the bank raycon's
mission is to prove that you shouldn't
have to pay an arm and a leg for Quality
sound and essential smart Tech listening
features you can get a pair and a spare
and still pay less than you would with
some of those other more big name Tech
Brands out there raycon knows that this
that in this economy every purchase
needs to be perfected they offer buy now
pay later options right now you can pay
as low as 18 and check out they have an
easy and free return guarantee they
offer two years of product protection
insurance for just a few bucks they
offer free domestic shipping and flat
for fee international shipping they have
50 000 five-star reviews three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functions noise isolation awareness mode
customers get tips for the perfect and
most comfortable in-ear fit Crystal
Clear call Quality Water and sweat
resistance eight hours of play time go
to buy right con.com Tim today to get 50
off your raycon order that's
byrankon.com to score 15 off by
raycon.com Tim you don't need to be
focusing on chipping what you need if
you have a business an online business
an e-commerce business the most
important thing you need to be focusing
on is the origination of business that
is the engine of any Enterprise whether
it succeeds or fails okay so I'm telling
you right now what you need to do is go
to ship station okay ship station hooks
you up with industry-leading discounts
you'll never have to worry about paying
overpaying for shipping get up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates and that's not enough
use my promo code to try ship station
for free for two months over 130 000
companies have grown their e-commerce
business with ship station 98 of
companies that stick with ship station
for a year become customers for life
okay they handle all the back end orders
getting it shipped hasn't been shipped
all the things that you are worrying
about right now ship station will take
over that side of your business it'll
become your back office and you will not
have to worry about it go to shipstation
dot com and use code Tim Dillon today
sign up for free free 60-day trial if
you're starting an e-commerce business
60 days of free shipping that's big
shipstation.com code Tim Dillon that's
shipstation.com code Tim Dylan that's
what I want what's going on with chicken
nuggets there's a chicken nugget story
in the news people are angry about their
nuggets
people are always going in chicken
nuggets oh they're poisoned oh we know
we know it's poison
what's happening McDonald's found liable
for Hot Chicken McNugget that fell from
Happy Meal and burned girl
there's nothing in this country better
than having a good scam
there's nothing better in this country
than having a good con
Fort Lauderdale Florida
of course
McDonald's and a franchise holder are at
fault after a Hot Chicken McNugget from
a Happy Meal fell on a little girl's leg
and Jesus caused a second degree burn a
jury in South Carolina has found
a second jury will determine how much a
McDonald's USA and its franchise owner
Upchurch foods will pay the child and
her mother
Thursday's decision was split with
jurors finding the franchise holder
liable for negligence and failure to
warn customers about the risk of hot
food
how hot was this nugget it just was a
fiery Little Nugget that fell on this
girl or did the mother
did the desperate mother
take the Nugget did A desperate mother
take a nugget in a car I want you to
Picture This a mother who's had enough a
mother who can't get ahead a mother who
knows
that things don't get better that's
movie [__]
she burns the Nugget with a lighter gets
it really hot and then presses it
against her daughter's leg I think
that's the only way this happens
philana Holmes testified that she bought
happy meals for her son and daughter in
a Drive-Thru window to McDonald's in
Tamarack near Fort Lauderdale
the south Florida Sun Sentinel reported
she said she handed the food to her
children who were in the back seat after
she drove away her daughter started
screaming no none of this happened the
mother testified she didn't know what
was wrong until she pulled over to help
the girl identified in court is Olivia
the newspaper reported she saw the burn
on the girl's leg and took photos from
her eye no this is
now listen baby mommy has to hurt you
right now
mommy has to hurt you but you know that
Mommy loves you mommy would only ever
hurt you if she had to right
yes yes Mommy
now it's gonna hurt a little bit when I
put this McNugget I lit up on your leg
you understand that and you go scream
and that's okay you can scream loud
but mommy's gonna get you something
beautiful after this okay
just lights the Nugget
the lighter
she said this is what it's come to you
know this is this is if you want to get
ahead this is what it's come to
you know Florida the land of the free
and you're lighting the Nugget and then
when that Nugget's so damn hot she's
probably holding the Nugget with like
something else because her fingers can't
even touch it so she's holding the
Nugget in the Nuggets like now he's like
[__] nuts and then she just goes
before she even has the chance to like
you know not do it before she has the
chance like second guess it she goes and
the girl goes and the girl just because
it's so she's branding her daughter with
a nugget and then she and then she goes
okay now we're gonna Sue because there's
no way by the way there's no way
this is the way things work okay unless
the kids are [__] no one picks up a
bag of nuggets he goes like this
and I would say this
if I was in court I would go okay so
what okay
the benefit of the doubt that okay
your daughter gets the Nugget back
and she goes like this
no you reach into the Nugget bag if
anything your daughter feels how hot it
is goes [__] me
I'm not eating that and the only Birds
would be on her fingers not her [__]
leg and then the mother's not getting
nervous she's like it's a color they're
going forensic on this they're going
forensic on this pretty good but I'll be
honest I'm a man who's been let's just
let's not lie to anyone I've been to
McDonald's
now when you go to McDonald's and you
get nuggets and I throw it in nuggets
every now and then as a novelty they're
not even good it's just something to eat
in between it's like instead of just
breathing you have nuggets when you go
to McDonald's order I usually get like a
filet of fish and a quarter pounder and
then in between eating instead of just
the breath that you would take you throw
a nugget in to just keep it keep it
going now
there's no way there's no everybody
reaches in you open the neck see the
nuggets are in a thing you open them you
open the nuggets
and he select a nugget and then a lot of
times you don't get in the sauce now
maybe kids are not using the sauce which
may have cooled the Nugget down maybe
the kids are not using the sauce right
now
but there's no way the kids are just
dumping the food on themselves that's
crazy right well you don't have kids
that's actually what they do [__]
kids
dumb kids do that smart kids do not just
take a whole bag of food a whole happy
meal and go
that people go well they dump it out to
get the toy yeah but they don't do they
dump it on themselves
and even if they did that the nuggets
the Nuggets I guess one nugget is so hot
none of the other nugget trap but
there's one molten nugget
s this is the claim the claim is that
maybe the daughter's excited oh there's
a Happy Meal toy and she dumps it out
okay because this is what the other
attorney will say and the judge by the
way wants to kill himself the judge is
like
okay
all right yeah now you're saying that
she was excited about the toy so she did
dump the food on herself
okay
usually they pick the toy out of the bag
the first thing and I would object I'd
go objection honor
most children pick the toy out of the
bag first and they start playing with
the toy and the parents have to be like
you actually have to eat your food they
don't still no one dumps it on
themselves no one dumps the toy on
themselves that's [__] they want to
play with it they pick it out of the bag
they pick the toy out of the bag
well we have studies that show that kids
are excited they don't okay but whatever
bring on your experts you bring on your
nugget Happy Meal experts we'll bring on
ours get your experts we'll get us but
the reality is this hot nugget which I I
do believe the mother probably
either brought a hot nugget from home
that she had
and heated it up real hot or just
torched it in the car
to the point where she had to burn the
daughter's leg
the child who's autistic did not testify
well that's convenient
well that's uh convenient
my autistic daughter can't testify that
I burned her with a nugget
yeah of course she can't testify because
she'd tell everyone that you took a
nugget out of your purse
held it under a flame like you were
cooking a crack rock and then burned her
leg to get some money
you can't tell anyone that because she's
autistic
by the way everyone's autistic now this
is gonna be a way everyone gets out of
everything I can't testify I'm autistic
you just stabbed someone I'm hey I'm a
neurodivergent I can't uh testify I'm
very good with numbers though so if you
want to do any I could do that
the girl's parents sued saying the
McDonald's of the franchise uh didn't
train employees failed to warn customers
about the dangerous temperature of food
and cooking the food too much to a
higher temperature while both sides
agree in the Nugget caused the burns
the family's lawyers argue the
temperature is about 200 degrees while
the defense said it was no more than 160
degrees
what a bad defense
what a horrible defense McDonald you're
arguing about 40 degrees of nuggets how
about how about no this [__] Burns her
daughter
how do you have a 200 degree nugget
can that happen I guess it can a 160
degree listen to this in a well-known
case from the early 1900s Stella live
x79 of Albuquerque New Mexico student
McDonald's over hot coffee that's built
on her lap in the car she received
significant injuries requiring
hospitalization and skin grafts well
that we understand but it's also like
it's hot coffee
yeah I remember this is what people
talked about in the 90s you know and it
was obviously it broke broke down
politically
you know the Libby Libs were like give
her the money [__] stop trying to
hurt people and the conservatives were
like it's hot coffee don't spill it on
your leg you're supposed to drink it
now can you get up the McDonald story
about the kid that choked on the
mozzarella stick that's why they no
longer have mozzarella sticks which I
this is what I've been led to believe
mozzarella sticks at McDonald's were
great and then one kid ruined it by
choking on it and dying and now looking
for again I I really believe is that
well what happened
the last okay the sticks are filled with
the substance that is composed what yeah
this is they they proved that they
weren't mozzarella cheese but no one
cares yeah it's not it okay no one cared
about that I think a kid choked on I
could be wrong about this but I I
seemingly remember
that during
the early 2000s I mean getting a
McDonald's mozzarella sticks with little
marinara was lovely and then I think
someone died a teenager who stopped
breathing and passed out after she
choked on her McDonald's was saved by a
good cinema okay that's not oh wait hold
on yeah
Charlotte Pape 17 had part of a
mozzarella Dipper it's called the stick
mozzarella stick Lodge in the throat
after she had a diabetic seizure outside
the drive-through restaurant in Abigail
Wales whose fault is that
that has nothing to do with the price of
tea in China
and they've taken away mozzarella sticks
um
because this [__] in Wales
got
sick you know she had a seizure and
anyone having a seizure is going to
choke on whatever they have
but this is what I mean like
almost puts up with a lot of [__]
from people
spilling coffee on themselves choking on
mozzarella sticks during seizures
and burning their kids with nuggets I I
there's something going on here with
this
unless they gave this [__] 200 degree
nugget but still the burn should be on
the fingers
ow not on the leg
it says it got stuck in between the seat
belt that's what it was what yeah it
says right here it says that uh the
Nuggets were not meant to be pressed
between a seed belt and human flesh for
more than two minutes wait a minute
wait one [__] minute
the Nuggets were not meant to be
president we seat belt and human flesh
for more than two minutes
so the hot nugget
somehow
gets between the seat belt and this
[__] for two minutes
I'm
like Mommy has to hurt you right now
do you want a pony
do you want to live on a farm do you
want all the bicycles in the world
because if you do mommy has to burn you
right now
mommy has to burn you bad and it's gonna
hurt
but mommy loves you and I'm telling you
she took the Nugget it's what I would
have done if I needed money no truly
if I needed money and I had an autistic
child I would burn them with a nugget
if I listen to me if I lived in Tamarack
Florida and I was nearing the end of
options
and I had an autistic child
and I'm sure they're fun for a little
bit but it gets a lot right
I'm just saying it probably does
and if I had it if I and I'm thinking of
ideas because you know this mother was
thinking of ideas all night going like I
don't want to kill her I'm not going to
Casey Anthony or I'm not gonna throw in
a backpack put her in the lake but I
wanna I need to get a little money and
she's looking at this girl going she's
not going to go on The Voice
you know it's fun when your kids like a
little bit of a star either as an
athlete or a performer and you're like
maybe they'll get me out of this dump
you know you take them to competitions
and they're like why
I am and you're like [__] yeah
everybody's like your kid's a star I'm
like hey hey you're damn right and but
then you got this thing
and you go well she's not this is not
this ain't little Brittany here Saint
Britney Spears here we're not she's not
getting us out with her Talent God love
her she's a beautiful lady and we're
happy we have her ish kinda but
We're not gonna throw We're Not Gonna
Kaylee we're not going to Kaylee Anthony
here we're humans
we're human beings we've thought about
it
we've thought about it
sure we've I mean everybody thinks about
drowning their kid but we're not gonna
die
but
you know she's sitting there with a
man's
and they're on the bed and he goes why
don't is there something that could
happen in a McDonald's
that would not really
change her life but would make us a lot
of money
and the mother's sitting there the
mother smoking a cigarette and
is like I could burn her with a nugget
if I took a nugget and heated it up to
about 200 or 350 like the hottest nugget
ever
and I burn her leg
and then I call McDonald's and I go you
[__] pieces of [__] my daughter has a
second degree burn
do you know how like second degree burns
like a real that's like a decent burn
and I think that's what the mother said
the mother was basically like and this
by the way I want all immigrants to be
able to do this that's why I'm I want
the immigrants the migrants to be
settled because I want them in 20 years
to be thinking of burning their children
with McNuggets so they consume
McDonald's I want an immigrant woman
having a child and thinking how can I
burn my autistic daughter with a
McNugget so I get a little money in this
world how do I come out ahead
how do I come out ahead here if I don't
burn my daughter with this nugget
just because
it's sad it's almost over
mother's pressing the Nugget on her leg
it's almost over look at me
now my autistic daughter cannot talk to
you right now
but she's very upset
than a nugget just came loose from her
bag
and ended up between a seat belt and her
thigh shut up don't don't ask why she's
autistic are you stupid
there was a girl in the back seat of my
car who was African-American and
autistic do you want to ask any more
questions no we don't no we don't uh
we're good on that and a nugget flew out
of her a 200 degree nugget
flew out of her bag and landed on her
leg and then was immediately stuck
between her leg and the seat belt for
two minutes where she suffered a
second-degree burn and now she can't
even look at nuggets and she has
seizures when we go near McDonald's she
just starts shaking
ah it's time to pay up
and that mother is going to be driving a
nice Beamer with the drop top and that
daughter is going to be sitting in the
back
A daughter's gonna be sitting in the
back and just like a big sun Bonnet like
not saying anything and you're going
through McDonald's Again by the way and
the daughter's getting big and the
mother's gonna go shut the [__] up
foreign
I know you don't like this place but
that's why we got this car
so I believe that I truly believe that
that's that is and I I I know it's a
comedy show but there is a possibility
that something like that happened
this feels odd
something feels odd here
and I do believe there is a possibility
this mother burned her child with this
nugget and that's why I focused on the
story today because
and I don't judge no one I don't judge
no one on this show
I have not walked a mile in her shoes I
don't know what she's gone through if
the only way out is to burn your
autistic daughter with a nugget in the
leg
[__] it I don't judge you I might not do
it I might I don't know I might I don't
know where she's at
I don't know where she's at
but I'm telling you right now I don't
judge anyone for their I'm just when
that girl can't speak when that [__]
does start to talk
she's gonna tell us a tale
when that girl starts to talk
what if this girl keeps having [__] done
to her like in a string of bad luck
[Laughter]
in a string of bad luck this girl lost
her eye to a french toast stick at
Burger King
it's amazing because the French toast
stick was so hot that it seared her eyes
shut and now she can't you know she
can't see
and that just happened a year later
odd what if this mother just takes his
girl around a different Florida you know
fast food restaurants in Florida and
maims her every time it's like a
munchausen's by proxy but it's all fast
food
this girl contracted HIV at Pollo
Tropical
at a Wawa this girl was gang raped
are they gonna age gate this again
is there going to age gate it again why
but I don't understand
I don't get this age gating
I don't understand but then if I go on
Rumble it's like Steve Bannon Roger
Stone and like the graphic is like four
lizard guys and then it's me
it's like I don't I can't do that
I'm just oh God
I don't know if they'll age gate this
but this is funny
but I don't know anymore I don't know if
they're gonna because of the last
section age gated but they shouldn't
it's all imaginary it's satirical
it's satirical
should we just be the age gate people
we're like there's only 200 000 people
that listen to the show and they all
sign in and they're like [__] it we know
it's gonna be Louis CK was like you
should do that just have everyone sign
in because they know it's like this is
not you know what I mean this is but you
know I'm hoping you know I'm I'm
exploring the news
because I do say that I'd burn an
autistic child McNugget I do say that
but I'm putting myself in the position
of a desperate mother in Florida there's
an art to this folks there's an art to
it and if you don't wanna if you don't
care you don't care I like I love my
audio people I love you guys on YouTube
too but I mean we got hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people about
half a million people that listen on
audio that just want to hear the show as
an audio show and I respect them and
then we also have the YouTube people
and they they've really [__] us
recently and you know I don't want to
talk about it because then it becomes
more real even though I am but that's
just kind of the way it is but you know
I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do anymore I can't think of
censoring myself
um because it is funny it is funny if
the mother goes she calls the lawyer and
goes my daughter's just getting raped in
a Wawa and they go we and they go listen
to me we no one went in the bathroom
after her we have the capes we have the
tapes you [__] liar
is this the girl that got burned with
the Nugget
is this the Nugget girl the girl that
got burned with the Nugget and the girl
where the [__]
where the French toast stick from Burger
King took out her eye
there's a moment of silence the mother
goes yes
and then she was getting raped to the
Wawa
and that's what you want you you're
expecting us to believe this
yes
that I mean it's just
timbilacomedy.com we have shows coming
up Denver Comedy Works the great club in
Denver we're doing
the one out in the suburbs because it's
bigger and it can hold more people in
Greenwood Village Colorado it's just a
small Drive outside of Denver and it's
Comedy Works South
27th 28th 29th we're gonna be there uh
Saturday July 22nd Las Vegas Nevada The
Encore Theater at the win Sunday the
17th San Francisco uh California at the
Masonic there are a few tickets left for
the Chicago Theater we are almost all
sold out at the Chicago Theater but
there's a few tickets left grab them
they will go Milwaukee Wisconsin the
paps theater there's some tickets there
Harris Resort in funner California I
was
I had made fun of this date but actually
after thinking about it and reading my
contract I've decided it's the greatest
thing in the world
because it's a casino in funner
California and I'm gonna be there
so to be honest
everyone should go
oh it's gonna be good I love it it's
gonna be fun it will be fun you need to
come
come because these casinos talk to each
other
come
remember Kamala she's like don't come
it's the opposite of that it's actually
come now you should go to that
um
Charleston and Hershey are doing great
with Shane and Nick and Jay and then
what else do we have what else do we
have
uh Parks Casino in September 8th and 9th
Bensalem Pennsylvania at Parks Casino we
have some new and big announcements
coming out live wise uh the book that
we're working on we're going to talk
about later and we're going to talk more
about it because
we do have a book coming out that I've
been working on and it's I'm very
excited about it
and there's some movies coming out next
year it's very exciting year
I'm praying they don't educate this
because you know I all I can do is pray
to the gods of tech to Linda yacarino
the new CEO of Twitter Twitter please
Linda yaccarino
yak attack
please you big ravioli you big Mussolini
supporting [__]
help me here I might move my show to
Twitter I'm telling you right now folks
if [__] YouTube keeps [__] with me
I will join Linda yaccarino and these
[__] guineas over on Twitter
I will join Linda yaccarino and those
little that that little Costco meatball
but no maybe we should maybe we should
do the show on Twitter can we
release it there I guess we we should
see how Tucker's Show Goes
that is true but I I will say that if
you know if people keep [__] with me
Daddy might have to just pull the shoot
and go over there with Linda yaccarino
and chemek plant parmesan
oh what are you done over there
over there they got an Italian running
Twitter
you know what the first thing she died
you got an Italian over there running
Twitter now
she made the character limit [__]
yelling come on
[Applause]
Lindy Ocarina you heard about this
they got a [__] Italian from the old
country
I am Bob you're running to it
you're an awesome
his impression is becoming it's like how
the Rogan one get for crazier his
Impressions becoming like a demonic
Force you know it's just like something
in the night like ah man
it's like it's a doll that's
malfunctioning
um but yeah I mean all I do is pray I
pray for the children
and for the future and for the hope and
for the hope of the you know so that's
to me
I just can't keep being [__] with by
these Tech utopians but that's why I got
Linda Yaks Lindy acarino
because she understands what it's like
to have an antipast
to have some [__] roasted red pepper
some Tomatoes some balsamic some oil she
understands focaccia bread she
understands a [__] spicy Wicket Tony
a little meatball a little garlic bread
a little Nona Sunday sauce
oh
mark
um
I don't think he likes me
use what I'd say Linda email me
I've met Elon I've met these people we
might have to go over there my what
about Tucker leading into the Tim Dylan
show
I mean when you talk about Prime Time
broadcasting over there
meatballs I'm not gonna call him
meatball and prep it's just funny she's
Italian
so now Tucker leads into like Tim I have
like the Late Night show until why do I
not have the Late Night show on Twitter
I should have the Late Night show on
Twitter things are moving things are
happening
you should be in entertainment shut up
yes
but I'm telling you
I'm telling you that I should absolutely
like push this further but maybe maybe
they won't [__] with me putting it out
there putting them Vibes putting the
Vibes Good Vibes
it's good vibes it's just good vibes
that's what the immigrants need the
migrants they need better vibes
the reality is because I see them and I
go not good vibes
they're getting off buses which ready
it's like
and then they're like holding towel I
don't hey we need Vibes this country
needs Vibes right now like chill
Vibes why don't we drop the migrants off
at Brooke and Connor Studio over with
the team here
can we drop 30 migrants at Brook and
Connor's Stadium
I will personally pay to drop 30
migrants off at Brook and Connor's
Studio
Connor would be like bruh there's people
outside
they're like I don't know the Vibes are
weird Connor they're migrants they're
from like a different place I feel like
a different place
yeah
where are they from they're from like
Central America isn't that like Texas
no like like just like South America she
knew like it's like Central South like
it's like different
whoa
they're like they're like cool though
like they're chill
there's like one guy and he's got like
one shoe that's like chill
Connor he like lost his shoe oh that's
[__]
it's like [__]
all right well we're gonna interview
them that'd be great I will drop off
I will drop off the migrants at Brooke
and Connor studio just see that that
would be great a migrant Town Hall
hosted by Brooke and Connor why not
like what can you expect when you come
to America and then Brooke and Connor
explain to the migrants like how America
works
have you been to Airline
everyone's like it's like it's like
healthy
and then it's like expensive
but it's like it's like super chill
you know it's like all these like just
[__] people that have no idea what's
happening
it's funny though it's funny it's a
funny idea like let influencers take
migrants around La and like show them
like what life is about
that's not a bad show
like that's something that I would get
behind like my like influencers bringing
migrants to like hot spots like Tana
Mojo teaching a migrant woman to take
her tits out she goes no you put your
tits out and then you take the photo and
that's how you get the money the Dinero
oh this is good it's not a bad idea
Timberland comedy.com buy tickets to
these live shows please because when
they take me off this [__] when they
take me out off the internet when Linda
yaccarino and [__] the Big Boss Man
when they take me off the internet
for making fun of them for making fun of
their Italian heritage
I'm gonna have to burn my daughter with
nuggets to get by good night